it took a while to get them here but the
children made it out safely and can play
or rest for a bit
they're orphans from eastern ukraine
who'd spent days in a basement taking
cover as russia targeted a military
installation nearby they made a 1600
kilometer journey to reach safety in
lithuania
we heard the missiles fly by and it was
frightening they make a whistling sound
as they pass
i'm afraid for those who did see that
[Music]
cruise missiles whirling past bomb
blasts in the distance seven and a half
million children in ukraine are in
danger of physical harm emotional
distress and displacement according to
save the children
it was very difficult for the little
ones when we were leaving they were
crying because they had to leave their
teachers it was very difficult even my
heart was broken because it's very
difficult for small children but seeing
how happy they are i think they like it
here
the 44 orphans get hot food and a roof
over their heads people here in
lithuania are giving what they can to
help and preparing local schools to
welcome them from our history we know
how devastating could be
invasion and devastate
lives of people
for many many
generations
so all the lithuania now experiencing
tsunami of goodwill
and support for ukraine
the children will need it to regain any
sense of normalcy to move past the
trauma of war
andrew chappelle aljazeera